look you know first let's talk about the
direct you know I thought they did a
fantastic job setting the proper
expectation you know for me personally I
feel like you have first of all gee this
100 right I was completely upset that
they did not show after game awards I
think that was a missed opportunity I
said before at nauseam they set the
expectation by being at the game awards
they showed the series X at the game
awards they showed hellblade at the game
award they showed a perfect dark at the
at that game award so Dave
they've opened themselves up to an
audience that is not familiar with the
Xbox brand it has the most eyes right
they didn't show up today I thought that
was a mistake now it's cost correction
they come out with a tweet after the
game was hey we've got something cooking
for you guys soon okay cool now green
comes out with the Tweet hey we're gonna
have a show developer direct I like
today you understand I don't mind
develop a direct developer focus seems
to be less personality focused which is
one of my issues with inside Xbox just
show me the games from the devs let's